Pass to be honest but I think that
entire movement a lab she talked about
has played a small role in it in that it
has I think raised the possibility and
the hope that one could be a little bit
more rigorous about what policies and
what type of things can really help the
poor because in two ways we go as in
designing the policies not based on your
intuition or whatever happens to be the
flavor of the month but based on a
better understanding of how the poor
leave why they make the choices they
make what are the specific traps that
hold them back and how to what lever to
push that could unlock these types that
are also more ego is also in the way
that accepting the possibility that
maybe you didn't get it right exactly
the first time and that innovating
experimenting is useful that is
something that of course the two of us
the three of us with Michael Kramer
could never have achieved but that is
something that this entire movement of
going at it with a lot of persistence
and a lot of details in the big and in
the small and small small project and
giant project for krisily as a chip and
I hope now with Japan North America and
Japan Europe and if a lack is that some
of this rigor that we try to develop in
the four countries moves back up north
and we also improve our understanding of
what are people's real trouble our
respect for them and their dignity and
their for a better more imaginative
solutions to solve these issues a bit
rightly put this in the broader context
of the big movements that is changing
development economics and as much be
honest I want to bring it back a little
bit to the more local environment of MIT
as you know I'm a MIT product oh and who
came to do my
here was hired as an assistant professor
against all norms never left when I made
this choice many wise people told me
that it was horrible career move and was
probably leading to physician I said I
understand that it's not good to stay in
your own institution but I think this is
here that I have the right and built
environment to pursue what I want to
pass you I have not been regretting this
choice in for any number of reasons and
I want to thank first of all the
department from my advice that's a bit
awkward because it's one of them and but
George angrist
the other one and Michael Kramer who
Girgis makes it doubly awkward and the
also the entire faculty who taught me
and all of the students who were with me
and I think together also this is not
about that
enjoyed as a student since he had the
misfortune of being down the road but we
also want to thank the department for
being a wonderful place to work and to
talk about economics and maybe in
particular bent on from who I think so
much before us the possibility of the
idea we had the first time we thought
about forming something he was the chair
of the department and he told us we both
vividly remember you have a project that
is going to make a big difference
I would like whatever and sure can you
get us a bit of money so we hired
and then the second very important
person in development of Japan and we
want to acknowledge here is Susan
Hockfield who when she came as president
of MIT just before L met us in fact I
think just before she became president
met us and we explained what we were
working on and she's like oh you're
bringing the middle of science to social
science this is so refreshing I'm gonna
help you and she was true to her word
and she helped us in many ways nurturing
always ready to talk and also quite
frankly putting us in front of possible
donors and in that we met I think
Mohamed Mohamud Jamil who is the third
person that we when you want to
acknowledge in the works of Japan
Mohammad German who's suing us maybe a
little bit like thanked and maybe for
for the same reason that he has business
acumen that none of us really had who
join us and in our project something
that could make a difference and decided
to risk his reputation and his money
behind that this would not have happened
without the ecosystem this would not
ever happen of course without his vision
and his commitment for the world's poor
which was very apparent then and still
apparent today
this is the type of outstanding people
that you want to have associated with
the University and finally I think on
behalf of both of us we want to thank
all the students the ones who have been
our students forever and who are some of
them are still in the room today some of
them are gone in the wide world who have
who have form a great big family isn't
community and all of the students who
are here who are not asked you don't but
make our days exciting every single
morning that we wake up and come here
and all of the staff of
but here and world well all maybe
hundreds of them and in particular the
leadership and the vision of question
glennister the first executive director
of jeepers and Nick Baldelli well who
succeeded her when she went on bigger
and better things
thank you very much for coming here on a
Monday of holidays we deeply appreciate
it
thank you so much for this beautiful
remark so in addition to those in this
room like I said there are many more
participating remotely by the phone
bridge and by the webcast today so what
we're gonna do just for the journalists
in the room is we're gonna alternate
between the room the phone bridge and
the webcast and I have some of the
webcast cards in front of me so we're
going to try to accommodate as many of
your questions as we can today so first
question from the room
I think combination of actually I think
by the time I understood what it takes
to get answers to empirical questions
right I thought the method and most of
that sounded hokey to me most of the
work that was seen as an established
truth in 1990 including my own work some
of it I thought it was a little bit
hokey and I and that made it much more
attractive to look for a method that
would give me a little more confidence
in what what we were doing and I think
that's what came out of mostly
frustration often with myself you didn't
wash angrist
and the way that I've been taught to
learn about the world is how you how can
you get as close as possible to a
randomized control trials so as soon as
I add a little bit more flexibility and
freedom and time I was like why do I
need to be close to a randomized control
trial where computers like do it any
more questions from the room before we
go to the bridge oh yes right over there
I will one our frequent I will believe
for education is as follows every kid
can learn but they cannot learn if they
are taught something that is so far away
from what they already knew that there
is nowhere they can catch up
unfortunately there are millions and
millions and millions of children who
are in school whose parents are very
excited about school who themselves are
very excited about school and get
completely discouraged within days or
within weeks because I understand what's
going on because they have no reason to
understand because they are taught
something that is way too advanced for
them and they are built they are being
made to understand that they are stupid
and they will never succeed we spend a
lot of our career and work with
wonderful and local pattern that we work
with to try and change that thank you so
we're gonna very quickly they're going
to take a question from the phone bridge
and they're gonna have to pipe the audio
explaining the instructions to the room
so we're going to do that right now with
my apologies
thank you for the audio participant that
is star one to ask a question do we have
our first question okay
[Music]
so I phone rang and I picked it up and
it says it's an important call from
Sweden and I thought to myself well know
that she woke me up just go ahead and
then someone very serious person told us
they told me that you've been awarded
the full name of the place that I don't
yet know and that is with Professor
Banerjee and professor grammar and I
said oh you want to talk to him and so
then they talked to him and then they
went back to us and said would you be
ready for for a press conference in an
hour we should make a cup of coffee and
I mean he said I'm gonna go back to bed
and so I woke up I got up I got showered
etc and he went back to bed I took a
press conference mind you they had said
they wanted they wanted just one of us
so that was fair enough and then we
started and I didn't qualify so I
actually have a question from the
internet but I'm gonna let you read it
they sent in French
they'd like you to answer in French if
you have in mind should I translate or
should I read in French and the answer
in French you should answer in French
but for the room you could do it in
English the question what does this
price signify for you to signify so
people who wanna number two is it the
proof that your approach is the right
one
ESCA silikov could wash it upon cousin
if it's a people knew how common is it
ladies
consecration the program int
accomplishes kisi enough wha da new mix
of two power truly shocked shocked I
have eczema totally partner to Laguna
more a sincere and exploring indication
case of Antonio capris the energy Chris
Tavano voila
por favor parfum you continue effect
contain Dominion person normal s-capepod
controversial but no abroad to inators
Apopka the respective Clara spectacle
eggs with work transcon with hot for
saleable maybe you don't know in a
puddle probe neutral positive one lab
serum cannot report lab on secure that
either the wrong key smart active on a
para Polly Polly Polly Polly cheek
canoes easy on the 2d beta-amyloid zero
self-control from our party we have one
from the bridge
someone there I can I go ahead yes
great congratulations professor
could you please summarize what your
work means for governments and
institutions we're in a place where you
feel in a material way for improving
outcomes among the poor there's always a
little bit of hoping for what we do so
it's not that
I mean governments are free to not use
our evidence but to be honest I think
our experience over the last 20 years
has been you know when you 20 years ago
you go and tell somebody in government
we're going to do a randomized control
trial and they look at you like you had
just escaped from some mental health
institution and now they look at you and
say that okay this is that is that
expensive does it has anybody else done
it can you can you can you give me an
example of somebody powerful who has
endorsed it but they ask the right kinds
of questions and and we get to the
second base not always all the way but
at least there is some sense in which
they're open to the idea that evidence
is valuable that we know something and
that might actually be useful to them
let me maybe give you an example a
concrete example maybe that's the
easiest so we run what's called
randomized control trials and the
objective of our most critical trials to
expect to run an experiment to see
whether something affects something else
the way you expect or in a different way
so I'll give you an example several
years ago we were interested in trying
to understand why people do not immunize
their children and what could be done
about it
and we spend a lot of time in India in a
very remote places in Rajasthan where
immunization rates were very very low of
the order of you know less than 5% full
immunization rate the availing view at
the time was that the the main problem
was that the munitions services were not
reliably available and that's why people
wouldn't get their immunization and it's
true that well munition service are not
reliably available sometimes you walk
for a long time to go to a public health
place you arrive there and it's shut
when you come back you've lost today no
musician that kind of frustrating and
then people don't do it again but
because we spend a lot of time in this
place and we interviewed people we
realized that another issue is that
people are always busy with other things
and with immunization if you don't with
these months you can always do it next
month it's really not ever an emergency
so it's never really on top of the list
for people to do it and the small cost
that means to go there and get it done
might be too too high even if it's a
very small cost so we thought okay let's
try and and test these two ideas we
worked with a wonderful NGO called sever
Monday and they in turn teamed up with
the government and told the government
we are gonna replace you for an area and
we are going to provide golden plate
ammunition services very reliable
services every month available in
at people - step in villages and then on
top of that so what they did is that
they picked 120 villages randomly that
is literally Weiser random number
generator the modern equivalent of a
dice picked half of them and put in
place those services in half of those
and then out of those 60 again randomly
picked 30 where they provided people
with this very small incentive to show
up to the munition camp was a kilo of
lentils per shot and a set of plates
when you finish so they did that they
did that for a year and what we did is
that we collected data on emission
status before and after and because the
places were randomly selected there is
nothing different about them except the
intervention any difference that we find
can be confidently attributed to the
program so what we found is that in the
statute school villages were nothing
particular was done emission rates by
the end of the experiment where 5% in
the places where they had done the
camp's but not the small incentive
emission rate has climbed to 12% which
is good more than doubling but in places
where they had indeed put on top of that
put this more incentive immunization
rate where 37% that gave us the kind of
indication that this was important and
from there we go in two direction in the
policy direction we pointed out that
it's actually cheaper to give incentives
and not to give incentive because the
nut has to be in the village anyways and
if she knows more kids it's it's cheaper
per shot so it's a good policy to pursue
on the intellectual side it sort of got
us to think about why is it that the
small incentive can persuade people when
you would think that it shouldn't really
be pertinent and got us to think more
about you know what how people make
decisions is it that what are they their
understanding of the healthcare system
what are their understanding of the
future on the present and and things
like that which has kind of spa
the whole agenda on understanding this
type of behavior so that's an example
that should clarify now multiply that by
thousand and you have the GPL type of
work in the room I mean to be honest I
think we hope that we'll get to do more
of the same I don't know I think well I
think we are actually quite excited what
we what we are doing this was not work
that we did a long time ago we're
excited about what we're doing now and
it's it's fun we are learning new things
I'm really excited to look at the
results from our latest intervention
it's so I think what I hope this will do
is just open more opportunities to do
more inventive things but I don't expect
to do something entirely different
I think it's I'm content with what what
I am doing enjoying it very much I think
maybe one thing that we have started to
do not just us but people in the network
as well is working with governments and
working at scale with governments to
help them evaluate both new approaches
but also better ways to do things that
they want to do anyways so this is our
larger project for example I gave you
the example of the immunisation project
which was in hundred and twenty villages
we are currently analyzing an
immunization project in the state of
Haryana that has 2,000 villages and
where the results that we are finding
will lead to statewide scale-up of
whatever works the best so so that's
kind of one place in which we are taking
it which is working directly with
government on life skills and the other
place and I think that's really again
not just us but the entire network is we
are constantly blown away literally by
how imaginative people
become in some of how they can decide
design projects we which not only help
us see what works and what doesn't work
but help us understand much better how
people behave how government behave how
politicians behave and in with wonderful
image the imaginative designs and we
want to do you know our best to be part
of that to the extent we can or
supported extent we can so this question
comes from Julia hood of Business
Insider for you professor to flow she
asks you are the second woman to receive
the Nobel Prize in Economics what is
your hope for the profession in terms of
inclusion but they are not enough women
in the economic profession at all levels
they are not enough undergraduates who
choose to take economics they are not
enough graduate students who continue
they are not enough assistant professor
they are not enough tenured faculty so
the reasons why they are so few women
who get bigger than the Nobel Prize are
other prizes is not because the people
who give prizes are not are discounted
against women it's because the entire
funnel it's just not big enough and
that's not true just for women I should
say it's too also for minorities they
are not enough african-american in the
economic profession by any stretch of
imagination in fact it makes women look
positively numerous when and that has to
change
but I think the reason it's the case is
because it's - maybe I'm home under
that's my understanding of the research
one is the the climate is a little bit
tough and aggressive and it doesn't work
for everybody
and in particular it's less likely to
work for women than for others this is
something that the profession is
starting to waken with and that's
wonderful and I think we get we will get
to the bottom of that it will take some
time but I think people are much more
aware that it is an issue I was not
aware it was an issue myself because I
don't mind aggressive it doesn't trouble
me but it had a lot of other people and
that's
unfortunate and it should not be doing
there's no reason to be aggressive
anyways the second reason I think is
because I think many women do not think
that economics is all that interesting
because the vision that occur makes easy
oh it's something maybe having to do
with finance or big macro policy or
whatnot and it has very little to do
with the problem that I care about
many women care about and the choices
that's not true not in fact a lot of
economics is about the type of work we
do obviously but the similar work in
public finance and labor economics
excetera in the on the US on issues that
are important education health but
people don't know that it doesn't really
calculate and one we should also
remember that they are not very Nobel
Prizes that has gone to people who
mainly work on social problems and so
being a woman working on social issues I
hope that it can also be kind of role
model for others to think you know look
actually it's pretty interesting this
field and it's much more varied than you
then you think one piece of just take
pride in one thing which is that in our
specific little corner of economics the
field of development economics has many
more women than most almost any other
part of economics and for example we
have a seminar series that Harvard and
MIT jointly run this semester it turns
out that I rationally said that all
those speakers are women but and this
was not because of any design it was
simply because these were the best
people and they were invited to give
come give talks turned out I was
slightly wrong they were actually two
men but so I I think organically it is a
field where I'm consistent with maybe
what Esther said which is that maybe
some parts of economics are not centered
seeing two women we don't have anything
like a comparable deficit which I really
do want to take some pride in all right
we have just a lot of cards from the
internet
Leticia Hernandez with elfin encierro in
Mexico she asks the United Nations warns
that they're the the pace of the fight
against poverty has fallen especially in
Latin America what policy should
governments prioritize to have effective
results in reducing poverty health food
education in some ways I think one of
the ways in which we distinguish
ourselves is by not answering those
questions I think we'd like to answer
these questions after we do the homework
I having an one answer for all of Latin
America based on never having really
studied Latin America that would be
irresponsible I don't think I think that
would be bad advertisement for our
particular style of work so that's to
say I won't answer it okay so we have
another one which maybe will be a will
not answer but we'll ask so NW 18min
gali News asks what is your opinion on
the state of the economy in India what's
in store for the future and they asked
if you could answer that that's a that's
a statement not about what will work in
the future but about what's going on now
that I'm entitled to have an opinion
about I feel dhikr is doing very badly
in my view it's if you one of the
numbers that just came out is the the
National Sample Survey which comes out
every one and a half years or so and
it's a gives you the average consumption
in urban and rural areas in India and
the fact that we see in that is that
between 2014-15 and 2017-18 that number
has slightly gone down and that's the
first time such a thing has happened in
many many many many many years so that's
a that's a very glaring warning sign
I this enormous fight going on in India
about which data is right and the
government has a particular view of all
data that's inconvenient - it is wrong
but nonetheless I think that this is
this is this is something that I think
even the government is increasingly
recognizing that there is a problem so
the economy is slowing very very fast
how fast we don't know is this
disputable data but I think fast he did
ask me to do some of it in Bengali no
Korra away what can we do about this
okay let me do I'll say the whole thing
in Bengali and then translate very he
Cora away so the multimedia Nina
Toby was the body Eckankar moto AJ a
modern monetary policy regime jettison a
sharper central Rishi the Sheraton
percentage in deficit sovereign issue
bellissima Takamine a Cooney economic
page connector for Santa even GUI will
have the positive or looking at the
pasta or nine curry will have them are
obese it happened early so I don't know
exactly what to do the government has a
large deficit but right now it's sort of
at least aiming to please everybody by
pretending to hold to some budgetary
targets and monetary targets and my view
is that this is the economic going into
a tailspin is the time when you don't
worry so much about monetary stability
and you worry a little bit more about
demand
I think demand is a huge problem right
now in the economy Julia hood with
Business Insider has a follow-up
how does political upheaval domestically
and globally impact your work either at
the research level or in its practical
applications does the private sector
step in there are few questions in that
she's
the US people domestic or verbal um I
don't think there is any direct impact
on our work in the sense that we can
mostly continue doing what we are doing
but there is certainly an impact in
terms of what we think is important and
where we should direct our energies
where we should try and understand a bit
better when you see the people that take
place for example here or in France or
in the rest of Europe then we feel oh
you know we we should also start
thinking about is there anything we can
bring to understand these issues and
even if it takes us slightly outside of
the comfort zone of our work till date
will be relying on all of the expertise
that our colleagues have so I think it's
more a matter of reorienting our brains
was in terms of specific kind of issues
and even on the geography aware of those
issues concerns are concern it's in a
sense it's kind of brought home for me
the current problems that the developing
the developed country faces brought home
for me that even when people's basic
material comfort is more less sustained
by the fact that they live in
environment with reasonable safety net
their full life might have the same
level of misery and happy and
unhappiness that some of the extremely
poor people we study and therefore that
is also something that is worth thinking
about very hard I used to think and to
some logics and I still think I should
direct my energy in thinking about the
poorest person in the world and then the
second worst person in the world and
inertia towards person in the world and
I realized that although that's
of course different to live in the
middle of nowhere and trying to deliver
a child and it's not going well and
there is no hospital that from feeling
miserable having lost your job in a
mining town in u.s. one also has to
understand those issues so building on
that question Swati sabe of mossy cave
magazine asked about the trend in d
globalization and asked specifically are
brexit America first and several other
protectionist campaigns an outcome of
capitalism gone wrong in your view is a
small question I be so I think they are
a consequence of us not taking the
consequences of globalization seriously
I think the globalization was hurting or
as you cannot miss our presumption is
that that hurt is temporary and it goes
away quickly because people react to
that by moving and changing jobs and
retraining we know now that those
processes are slow and as a result
people actually get quite badly hurt so
I think it is a sense in which I would
say it's not so much that I don't know
whether this means capitalism went right
or wrong it does mean that I think the
way the policy response to the pain
caused by globalization was inadequate
often even in the wrong direction
so I do think that that's what it's
partly telling us and that student from
the internet asks for you professor
Banerjee what is your feeling about
being the sixth Nobel laureate from
Kolkata
young student I mean III assume they're
all much more distinguished than me more
in the room so we have two children aged
five and seven who believe that they are
the center of the universe and they do
not accept kitchen table conversation so
that was kind of the kitchen table part
was had to have to go everything else is
fair game
so we I think we in our walk is our life
life is our work a lot of thing we love
to do but it turns out you can do a lot
of things we love to do while cooking a
bit it spends a lot of time cooking and
we can cook and talk about whatever is
happening we took while walking to work
and coming back and we also talk about
the children when we are office at MIT
so I guess it's like a mix
anymore from the room at the phone
bridge right we might be our last one
it's another one asking if you might
answer in French trying
it's Omaha do Canada Luca Montero sujet
Laplace the Furman economy oh I already
said that in English they wanted in
front service and a report on it up
double crochet the next steps of your of
your research doctor Vig mr. Koo Jin Yan
only on francais ah yep I see the family
from Laguna me a tuna Nero because what
a meal easy to do Tommy Leontes layer
giant professor or the focus of radhaji
a sexual skip would show G it's just
something in armament program for fire
ant relief Donna carrier sentence eat my
own economies occipital viola party bus
curve back on a very uneasy dress can
see a similarity a non-periodic problem
in a natural do problem
phenomena lipet a gnome kiev a pollution
then pow wha-pish the famine economy
vasco the diversity this opinion a
difference today's experience the
diversity dysentery if you see the
languages do not the neutral men don't
response cuz it intentionally Pascal is
a soon commence
I love walaikum Hodgman and I couldn't
do professor it would see the data
making may of communication does confess
could is economists for me ProQuest
until I saw men poured a member of the
firm I don't respect her was in certain
reserves they took as you know
contribute a trample to do the Moodle
the whole Moodle course of significance
fair proportionate up the nutrition
department affirmed is a dead president
my continuing continuing have I
continued a awake am occupancy pile of
families experience don't do
don't move on to our deputy they go on
the buoyancy continua we are whole I
mean you're allegedly the people you see
but actually the person up amount over
Mickey saw her coming autonomous
pre-madonna Co are there any more in the
room student okay then our last one is
gonna be something of a layup I think to
highlight your website so a journalist
asks how can we learn more about the
methodologies to make randomized
controlled trials that will impact our
societies that would be a nice one and I
[Laughter]
encourage you to go to our the website
of the poverty action lab where all of
our work and the work of others is
described displayed so that's a WWWE
action lab god that sounds really put
some juice but we have a book well we
have two books one of them is has been
out for some time and it's po economics
and it's a book that builds on the
research of all of the field in
development to try and explain but
without understanding of the problem of
poverty education health governance
excetera
it also explains the methods in in a
role of details so that's the place and
even more presumptuous we have another
book coming out in a month that's good
that's called good economics for hard
times and it's a 300 pages elaboration
of what we just discussed today how the
times are hard and they are hard for
people in much deeper way than perhaps
we had realized and it turns out that
economics has a lot to say about why the
time
are hard and what to do about it and the
unfortunately again the vision that
people have of economics is not that
they think economics are economists are
not to be trusted in fact the only
people who are less trusted than
economists about their own field of
expertise are politicians both of which
are not very good and so with what we
are trying to do in this in this book is
R'lyeh
even more on the results of other people
to show what economists have to say
that's in a more subtle and useful way
on the big problems that affect us today
that immigration and trade and
automation and the rise of bigotry and
and also of course since this is our
sensibility on social policy and what to
do about it so that was the
advertisement
so it's been an amazing nearly hour-long
press coverage that we've had you up
here so thank you so much for your
patience and time just for those just a
journalist just a few housekeeping items
those seeking images or more information
from MIT
the email is questions at MIT edu we'll
get you what you need you can also look
for us in the room the faculty will be
here for a little bit doing some
one-on-one stand-ups with some of the
cameras and then the webcast will be
archived online and we will have an
audio recording of today's event that we
can share with you thanks again to all
who could join us